this
is great big story a place to meet
the most fascinating people on earth
and after five years it's time for us to
close our doors
[Music]
there are untold stories all around us
our mission was to find the most
surprising ones that could change the
way
we see the world click
in the best part you came along for the
ride
you made up an audience of over 12
million fans all around the world
[Music]
watching over 180 million minutes every
month
we saw our community of adventurers and
storytellers grow
making us feel closer to our neighbors
from every corner
of the planet through our microdocs
series and short films
[Music]
we told over 2600 stories
in more than 100 different countries
we'll always believe that there is magic
in the world
that the amazing people doing improbable
things deserve a voice
and their stories are best when told
so thank you for taking this journey
with us
while our chapter is coming to a close
there are many more ahead
we all have a great big story
now go tell yours